the surprising thing about motherhood to
me so far has been how it's intensified
my activism and philanthropy ladies and
gentlemen the Holly rod Humanitarian
Award goes to Eva Longoria Bastogne
Eva Longoria Bastogne is all about
giving back so much so that the actress
was honored by the HollyRod foundation
on Saturday for all that she does to
better the community my philanthropy my
charity has just gotten more intense for
this community that we share we want to
help so many children and not only the
children with disabilities but their
families and siblings and parents the
proud mama who gave birth to her son
Santiago in June 2018 opened up to ET
about how motherhood has intensified her
passion to make the world a better place
now I'm like oh I have to leave the
world a better place for my son like it
really really matters and so so for me I
think it's not about telling Santi how
to be it's about showing him by example
and I'm really blessed to have an
amazing family that all leads by example
and hopefully he'll follow those steps
from an early age Eva said her family
showed her the importance of doing good
it was in my DNA I come from a very
giving family I you know my my older
sister as a mental disability and my
mother's a special education teacher my
sister's special education teacher so
I've always been around those who are in
need and I've seen these programs work
in different communities and in
different ways and so when I see
effective sustainable change that is
happening one family at a time one child
at a time it makes me just want to do
more with a busy career and family life
eva is proud to be an example of a woman
who does it all
I think managing time well is important
I have an amazing husband I have an
amazing family I have amazing friends
and when you have that community around
you helping you raise your child and it
really does take a village and so I'm
lucky that I can travel
with my son and travel you know wherever
I need to go to do work but also have
that kind of village along with me